RONALD SMITH: So now we
are into this new section of
the course, oceanography.
And last time I gave an overview
of the nature of the
ocean basins, basically the
geometry of the basins in
which the water sits.
We connected that to plate
tectonics, both to make the
point that those ocean basins
are changing through geologic
time, but also to get at this
curious issue of how the
oceans are not just kind of a
random roughness on the Earth,
but they really represent two
basic levels of Earth crust.
The continental crust which
sits a bit higher, and the
ocean crust which sits
a bit lower.
And that's why there are these
vast areas of the ocean that
are at about the same depth
below sea level,
these abyssal planes.
It's an oversimplification to
say, of course, that the ocean
basins have flat bottoms like
a bathtub or something.
But there is a little bit of a
tendency that way because they
do have--they do have ocean
crust beneath them which
floats at a certain level and
gives you the depth of about 5
kilometers in many, many places
around the world ocean.
Some places are deeper, some
places are shallower, but
there is that reference level
from which we work.
Any questions on that?
Then we moved into a discussion
of how to measure
salinity and temperature in the
oceans, and I talked about
some of the methods
to do that.
And I wanted to pursue that just
a little bit further, and
then get into some quantitative
methods for
estimating how the atmosphere
forces various things that go
on in the ocean.
So let me just start here, and
I showed you this last time.
This is a typical
ocean sounding.
Zero refers to sea level, and
then depth is in meters below
that, and this one going
down to 4,000 meters.
The temperature is shown here
with a distinct cooling as you
go down that starts pretty
quickly below the surface.
Maybe in this case, just a
couple hundred meters below
the surface you go from a
mixed layer to a strong
gradient region called the
thermocline, "cline" referring
to change, and "thermo",
of course, referring to
temperature.
Then you get down to
temperatures below that that
are four, five, six degrees
Celsius and colder, and that
fills most of the interior
of the ocean basin.
So this point I was emphasizing
last time about
how the surface temperature does
not represent the deep
ocean temperature is
shown nicely here.
Salinity is somewhat similar
in that you can have strong
gradients near the air surface,
but more uniform
conditions below.
In this case, it's saltier, then
gets a bit fresher, than
gets very slowly
saltier below.
But always staying in this
remarkably narrow range
between 34 and 35 and 1/2
parts per thousand.
Then the dynamical quantity
we're interested in is the
seawater density with units
that you're familiar with,
kilograms per cubic meter,
for example.
And that is a generally
a function of
temperature and salinity.
The warmer the water is, the
more it expands a little bit
and its density is less.
The colder it is, the
more it contracts,
the density is greater.
And salt, when you add salt to
water, the salt goes a little
bit into the pores between the
water molecules, which
increases the density.
So the greater the salt content
the greater is the
density, and the fresher
the water is the less
is the water density.
And since density is what
gravity acts on, we're
particularly interested
in this.
For example, if you wanted to
apply the hydrostatic relation
to find out how fast pressure
increases with depth, you'd
want to use the density derived
from the salinity and
the temperature.
The word pycnocline is used when
you're referring to this
gradient region as it
applies to density.
So here it's the halocline
referring to the salt, there
the thermocline referring to
the temperature, and the
pycnocline refers to that
combined quantity which is the
density of the water.
These profiles vary from place
to place in the world ocean.
For example, the high latitudes
where you might have
a lot of precipitation and
because it's cold, not very
much evaporation.
The surface waters, notice the
salinity scale is reversed on
this diagram.
The water might be a little
less saline at the surface
than it is down deep.
Whereas in the tropics, for
example, in the belt of
deserts, the descending branch
of the Hadley cell, you'd have
a lot of evaporation, but very
little precipitation.
So the water near the surface
would be salty there, but not
at the bottom.
The bottom is more
homogeneous.
Let's take a look at the salt
itself, and this will connect
a little bit with the lab that
you're currently writing up.
So if you take a kilogram of
seawater, about 965 grams of
that is water, H2O, and about
34.4 of that is in weight, in
mass, grams, is the salt.
Then if you break up that little
salt wedge into its
chemical compositions you get
this little pie chart here.
It shows the most
abundant ions.
So assuming that this quantity,
these chemicals
break apart when they dissolve
in the water into their
positive and negative ions.
By far the largest contribution
is the chlorine,
18.96 grams of the 34, a little
more than half of that
salt mass is due to
the chlorine.
And let's look at the other
negative ions here.
There's a sulfate radical,
SO4, and there's a
bicarbonate, HCO3 with minus
signs for the charge.
Then we come to the cat ions,
which is what you're studying
in the lab this week.
The dominant ones are sodium,
which is by far and away the
most abundant.
But also we have magnesium,
calcium, and potassium.
Those are the four things that
you have data for in the lab
as you go from fresh water
river into the ocean.
So you might want to compare
these numbers that I have here
in lecture, the 10.56 grams
per kilogram of seawater.
The 1.27 for the magnesium, 0.04
for calcium, and 0.38 for
potassium with the
values you had.
But just remember, when we got
to Long Island Sound we only
had a salinity of about half
that of ocean water.
So you should divide these
numbers approximately in half,
or double your numbers before
you do the comparisons.
But I think that'd be useful to
try to understand how our
measurements agree with the
textbook values for what makes
up the salts.
The reason they can make a
diagram like this is these
relative proportions are the
same everywhere you go in the
world ocean.
Even when the salinity varies a
little bit, maybe down to 34
or up to 36.
These all increase
in proportion.
So that these relative numbers
are quite stable when you go
from place to place in
the world ocean.
And of course, our simple theory
of this is that this
represents an accumulation over
geologic time of small
amounts of these chemicals,
these salts, that have come
into the ocean from rivers.
And you're testing that idea
in using your lab data.
Any questions there?
Now, you remember in the
atmosphere we spent a good
deal of time talking about
static stability, that is, we
looked at the role of the
atmospheric lapse rate how the
temperature changes in the
vertical to whether parcels
can rise and fall
easily or not.
Or whether that atmosphere might
even be unstable and
break down to convection.
So we defined an unstable lapse
rate, a stable lapse
rate, the inversion, which was
an example of a very stable
lapse rate.
We're interested in the same
kind of analysis in the ocean.
But there's a couple of
essential differences.
One is that the ocean density
depends not just on
temperature, but on
salinity too.
So we'll have to take into
account both of those
quantities.
We'll do that simply by
computing the density.
We'll base our stability
analysis on water density,
rather than on temperature
or salinity alone.
The other big difference
is that while air is
compressible, so as a parcel
lifts in the atmosphere and
moves to lower pressure, it
expands does work on its
environment and its temperature
changes.
That affect is very, very
small in the oceans.
It's not exactly zero, but it
is so small that for many
quick calculations we ignore
that volume change and that
so-called adiabatic cooling or
adiabatic warming as air
parcels rise up and down
in the atmosphere.
We ignore that in the ocean.
So because of these two
differences, the idea of what
determines stability in the
atmosphere and the ocean are
significantly different.
The basic principle is that
while temperature and salinity
can either increase or decrease
with depth, the
density derived from them must
always increase with depth.
We saw that in the earlier
diagram here that the
salinity, for example, decreased
with depth, then
increased with depth.
But when I computed the density
it increased smoothly.
If there was ever a layer where
the density got less
with depth, that would be an
unstable layer, and it would
immediately cause convection
and would mix.
Years ago when I first starting
out, I was looking at
some CTD data from a
ship and thought I
found an unstable layer.
Went running up to the chief
scientist to show him this
remarkable discovery, and he
quickly pointed out where I'd
made a mistake in
my calculations.
So once again, the ocean
was found to be stable.
It's been proven many,
many times.
The point is, you could have
an unstable layer, but it
would exist only minutes because
immediately convection
would begin, that layer would
mix, and you might produce a
layer of constant density from
that mixing, but you would be
unlikely to sustain any layer
that is unstable.
So you should always expect
to find this kind of
relationship, and if you don't,
you've either made a
wonderful discovery, or somewhat
more likely you've
screwed up your calculations
when you compute a density
from temperature and salinity.
So it's a very important
principle.
Probably almost universally true
in the atmosphere--in the
oceans, sorry.
So yeah, so there it is.
Now, this diagram is nice
because it combines together
hundreds of CTD and Nansen
bottle data sets from three of
the major world ocean basins the
Pacific Ocean, the Indian
Ocean, and the Atlantic Ocean.
What I like even better about
this diagram is that it's
superimposed.
These balloons of data are
superimposed on a diagram that
has lines of constant
density on it.
Let me walk you through those
lines first. So on this axis
is the salinity in parts per
thousand that we're used to
working with, PPT.
On this axis is temperature
in degrees Celsius.
And then these lines are lines
of constant seawater density.
And by the way, so what
is this unit here?
This unit is the density of
seawater with the 1 and the 0
dropped off.
So you would read
this as 1,028.5
kilograms per cubic meter.
And since it only changes in
those last couple of digits,
we don't want to keep writing
that 10 in front of all of
those values.
But you can see that the density
is greater down here,
29, 28.5, and 28.
And that corresponds to salty
water and low temperatures.
And the seawater density is less
up here, 25, 24.4--24.5,
and 24 for high temperatures
and low salinity.
So that's as we thought
it would be.
Are there any questions
on that?
There's a couple of other things
I'd like you to notice
about this diagram.
Up in the warmer temperature
region, up near the top of the
diagram, because of the way
these lines are tilted, the
density is most sensitive
to temperature changes.
Whereas down in the colder
regions where the lines are
tilted more like this, the
density is more sensitive to
salinity changes.
So when you're talking to a
tropical oceanographer, and we
have one in our department,
Professor Fedorov. He is
usually most interested in
talking to you about the
temperature profiles
in the ocean.
Of course, he hasn't forgotten
that salinity
plays a role in this.
But in the tropical in the warm
parts of the ocean, the
temperature is the primary
control on the density.
If you're talking to an Arctic
oceanographer, and we have one
of those in our department,
Mary-Louise Timmermans.
She's usually most interested in
understanding the salinity
field because the salinity field
hacking down here, as
you can see, is more in control
of the density field
in the colder regions
of the ocean.
So I don't want to exaggerate
that too far.
Both are always playing a role,
but in warm areas it's
mostly the temperature, in cold
areas it's mostly the
salinity that's controlling
the density.
Any questions on this diagram?
So let's look at these
big kind of balloons.
The Pacific Ocean is generally
a little fresher, and maybe
even a little bit warmer than
the Atlantic Ocean.
There is a little part down here
which is common to both
oceans, they come together
down there, called the
Antarctic Bottom Water.
We're going to be talking about
that probably next time.
It's a mass of water that's
produced near Antarctica.
It flows Northward along the
bottom of the ocean, and we
find it in both the Atlantic
and the Pacific.
So there's a common element.
But other than that, there
is a general systematic
difference between the Pacific
and the Atlantic Ocean.
And that, of course, has to do
with atmospheric controls,
which I'm just about
to get to.
If you do a cross-section,
this happens to be a
North-South cross-section
through the Atlantic Ocean
from high latitudes to low.
Perhaps you can't read
in the back, but
the Equator is there.
10 degrees North, 20, on up to
60 degrees North, and on down
to minus 70 degrees latitude,
70 South.
Here's a depth scale going from
0 down to 6 kilometers.
And then the horizontal scale
is what I indicated.
And contoured here
is temperature.
Temperature actually gets a
little bit below 0 here.
Minus 0.2.
But by the time you're up in
here it's 1.2 degrees, 2.4.
And then you've got some strong
gradients near the top,
well that's the thermocline, and
then near the surface of
the ocean in the mid-latitudes
and low latitudes, you have
this little lens of warm water
floating on the surface.
Many of you I expect have been
swimming in a fresh water lake
in early summer.
You may have noticed that as
you swim out, the water's
pretty comfortable in terms of
this temperature, but when you
stop swimming and let your
legs dangle down a bit,
suddenly it's a lot
colder down there.
What's happening is that that
fresh water that's warm is a
little bit less dense
than the cold water.
So it floats in a little
layer on top.
Well that's exactly what's
going on here.
There's salinity involved, but
mostly it's a temperature
control, and you've got a warm
layer of water kind of
floating in a broad, deep,
cold layer of ocean.
And you'll find this as you go
North to South in all of the
world's oceans, you'll find
this thermocline that
separates this warm sphere from
the deep cold sphere.
That's kind of a common element
in both the Atlantic,
the Pacific, and the
Indian ocean.
So we'll talk more about
that later on.
Any questions on what
this diagram shows?
By the way, this blue water
here, that's that Antarctic
Bottom Water that I
was talking about.
I'll come back to that.
Are there any other simple
analogies to this?
Well, I would point you to the
Great Salt Lake as kind of an
analogy to the world ocean.
The Great Salt Lake
unlike most lakes
doesn't have an outflow.
When water flows into the Great
Salt Lake in Utah, it
doesn't spend a few weeks there
and then flow in some
river into the ocean.
No.
It basically stays there
until it evaporates.
This is a no outflow lake.
And for that reason, you get the
same kind of concentration
of salts, the same process,
as you do in the ocean.
So it's a little mini ocean, if
you like, in the sense that
it has to evaporate its water,
get rid of it, and therefore,
it concentrates the salts.
Now, in this case, it
concentrates the salts even
much more than the ocean does.
The salinity is three
to five times
saltier than in the ocean.
Has anybody swum in the
Great Salt Lake?
Dip your body in it?
But you've heard about
it, right?
The remarkable thing is
how high you float.
You're sitting there, and maybe
from here on up you're
out of the water.
Why?
Because the water is salty,
and therefore more dense.
Following Archimedes rule, the
denser the water is, the more
mass you're displacing, the more
the buoyancy force, the
higher you float.
So this is a good thing to think
about when you're trying
to understand basically
how oceans work.
It's kind of a little
mini ocean.
Now, the subject I was going to
get into today, and I will
get into it is atmospheric
forcing of the ocean.
For the most part, any motions
you have in the ocean, in
fact, almost everything that
goes on in the ocean, is
driven from above by either
sunlight hitting the ocean, or
some other interaction with
the Earth's atmosphere.
Now is there any forcing
from below at all?
Well there is a little bit of
geothermal heat coming out of
the bottom of the ocean
basins, but
that's quite small.
So except for that, it's pretty
much the oceans are
driven by the atmosphere
from above.
These three things are
how that happens.
You can add or remove heat at
the top of the ocean, either
by radiation, the Sun's
radiation, or long-wave
radiation emitted from
the ocean surface.
Or by contact with
the atmosphere.
if you have cold air, that'll
suck heat out of the ocean.
If you have warm air that'll
conduct heat into the ocean.
Or you can add fresh water by
precipitation, or remove fresh
water by evaporation, leaving
the salt behind.
These two things will change the
salinity of the surface,
and therefore, the density.
And this one will change the
temperature and, therefore,
the density.
Or you've got the wind stress.
You've got the wind blowing
over the ocean surface
transferring some momentum to
the ocean, and getting the
ocean moving in that way.
So we're going to need to
understand each of these three
mechanisms. For example, here
is our best estimate of the
heat flux in and out
of the ocean.
Basically, where you get, for
example, cold water and warm
air, the heat is going into the
ocean, and that's shown as
positive on this diagram.
Where heat is coming out you've
got the blue or the red
color shown as negative.
But it varies from
place to place.
It depends on the
air temperature.
It depends on how much sunlight
is being received.
It depends on the water
temperature, whether heat is
going into the ocean or whether
heat is coming out.
We'll talk about this
quantitatively in just a moment.
Then the other one is E minus
P or P minus E. This one is
evaporation minus
precipitation.
The sign is derived
in that way.
So whenever water is
evaporating, you get a yellow
signature here, and the
units on this are in
millimeters per day.
How much water is being peeled
off and evaporated in terms of
a layer depth per day.
Whereas in the blue, and you
notice it coincides with the
ITCZ, for example, where you
have heavy precipitation,
precipitation exceeds
evaporation.
So the sign of this quantity of
negative shows up as blue.
Then you get up into
mid-latitudes again where it's
colder, there's less
evaporation, but you have the
frontal storms, and once again,
you're getting an
excess of precipitation
over evaporation.
So this is driving motions
in the ocean as well.
Then the final one is the winds
over the ocean, which
change a bit with the season.
There's January, there's July.
But generally you've got
Westerlies in the
mid-latitudes and Easterlies
in the low
latitudes in both seasons.
And that is generating motions
in the ocean itself.
So that is where we'll end
the pictures today.
And I want to get into
quantifying these things.
So here I've repeated those
three ways in which the
atmosphere forces the ocean.
Adding or removing heat,
precipitation and/or
evaporation, and the
wind stress.
Now, I want to make a further
distinction from this.
I've got a little--I've drawn
a little cartoon down here.
Here's the cloud that's
precipitating, adding fresh
water to the surface
of the ocean.
There's some evaporation,
that's this one.
Here's some heat being added
or removed, either by
radiation or by the effect
of the atmosphere itself.
And here's the wind stress I'm
going to use Greek letter Tau
to represent that.
But I've indicated that there's
a layer which feels
these inputs directly, and
that's called the depth of
that capital D. That will vary
from time to time and place to
place, but typically that's a
very small fraction of the
ocean depth.
When I do examples, I often
set D equal to 100 meters.
Roughly only the first few
tens or couple of hundred
meters feels these
inputs directly.
The rest of the world ocean will
feel them, but it'll be
an indirect influence.
Something coming not directly
from the atmospheric input,
but something then coming out of
this other layer that feels
a direct influence.
So be aware that I'm making this
distinction for all three
of these categories
of forcing.
My first job is to figure out
what does it do to this layer
that feels the influence
directly.
The first one will
be adding heat.
And you remember that if you add
a certain amount of heat
to a mass, M, with a heat
capacity C sub P, it's
temperature will change by
delta T. We've had that
formula before.
If I write that in a per unit
area basis, I'll divide the Q
by A, and the mass by
A, and I'll leave
everything else the same.
I've just divided both sides
through by the area that I'm
considering, which in
oceanography we don't usually
even consider that area.
We just do these calculations
on a per unit area basis.
The mass per unit area, if you
think of a piece of the ocean,
a little cylinder of area A, its
total mass is going to be
its volume times the density
of the water.
And the volume is going to be
the product of A and D where D
is the depth of that cylinder.
So the mass per unit area here,
which divides out the A
is going to be the product of
rho D, the water density times
the depth of the layer
that I'm considering.
So then let me just take that
and plug it into this formula.
I get Q over A that's the heat
being added per unit area.
Plugging this and I get rho D
CP delta T, and solving that
for delta T, I get Q over A
over rho D C sub P. And I
think we've seen that
formula before, but
there we have it again.
This will tell you how much the
temperature of the surface
layer of the ocean changes
when you put in a certain
amount of heat per unit area.
And it depends on the density of
the seawater, the depth of
the layer over which you're
distributing that heat, and
the heat capacity of water.
So a quick example of that I'm
going to take a solar flux of
1,000 watts per square meter.
Let's say we have sunlight
hitting the surface of the
ocean with that kind
of intensity.
That persists for one day,
which is 86,400 seconds.
So let's say that persists
for one day.
And that heat is distributed
over a depth of 1,000 meters.
How much will the temperature
of the surface ocean
change in that case?
Let's just put the numbers into
the formula that I'm just
extending this formula over.
So to get the heat,
I need to multiply
remember this is watts.
That's a rate of putting
in heat.
A watt is a Joule per second.
So I need to multiply the time
by the watts to get Joules per
square meter, which is what Q
over A means, that's Joules
per square meter.
So that's going to be 8.64 times
10 to the seventh Joules
per square meter up top that's
just the product
of those two numbers.
And then down below I'm going
to put in a estimate for
seawater density, a depth of
100 meters, and the heat
capacity for water which is
about 4,200 units of Joules
per kilogram per degree.
That's C sub P, you work that
out, and you might want to
check me, but I got 0.2
degrees Celsius.
So the warming turned out to be
pretty small because that
heat got distributed over a
pretty great depth, and the
mass of that water
is large, and its
heat capacity is large.
So although I put in almost 10
to the eighth Joules for every
square meter, the rise in
temperature was pretty small.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Is that supposed
to be 1000 meters?
PROFESSOR: That's
supposed to be I made the
mistake here, 100
meters, sorry.
Thanks for pointing that out.
100 meters, yeah.
That'd be too deep.
Very rarely does the ocean mix
down to 1,000 meters, as you
saw in the diagram.
By the time you get down to
1,000 meters you've got a lot
of gradients and things like
that, so it doesn't usually
mix that deep.
So you can apply this to a wide
variety of circumstances,
depending how you alter
the input numbers.
The heat could come from the Sun
like I've done, it could
be a loss of heat by
radiating to space.
It could be a heat transport
from the atmosphere in or out
of the ocean, depending where
remember the diagram I showed
you some parts of the
world is positive,
some parts it's negative.
So this number's going to depend
on where you are, the
season of the year, and so on.
Now, the next one will
be number two.
This is a little trickier.
Let me define the salinity as
the mass of the salt over the
mass of the water in any
particular sample that you
have. I'm going to be looking
at change, so I'm going to
define salinity at time 1 as
being the mass of salt at time
1 over the mass of
water at time 1.
And salinity at time 2 as
being MS2 over MW2.
But I'm not going to consider
cases where I'm adding and
removing salt.
That doesn't happen very
often in the ocean.
Instead I'm going to consider
cases where I add and remove
fresh water.
Either it rains, so I'm adding
fresh water, or it evaporates.
When it evaporates it leaves
all the salt behind, so you
can say that I'm subtracting
fresh water.
So I'm going to assume that in
the changes I'm about to
describe that MS1
is equal to MS2.
So I'm not changing the mass of
salt in the sample, but I'm
going to change the mass
of salt water.
I'm going to define the change
in salinity as being S2 minus
S1, and just using these
formulas that'll be MS over M
water 2 minus MS
over M water 1.
And notice I've dropped the
subscript now on the MS
because I'm going to assume
that the mass of
salt doesn't change.
With just a little bit of
manipulation I can rewrite
this as MS over M salt water
1, M water 1 over M water 2
minus M Salt over M water 1.
What I've done is just multiply
and divide the first
term by M water 1.
You see it there and there.
I've just multiplied and divided
by the same number.
But now this can be rewritten
as the salinity at time 1
times the bracket M water
1, M water 2 minus 1.
So the change in salinity is
related to the salinity you
started with, plus the ratio of
the fresh water you started
with to the fresh water
you ended with.
That's an M sub W sub 1, and
an M sub W sub 2, the fresh
water that you have.
Now I'm going to try to motivate
this a little bit
geometrically.
Imagine I've got a column of
seawater, perhaps some little
section of the surface layer of
the ocean I just sliced out
with a cookie cutter.
And then I add a layer
on top of it.
It'll be capital D in its depth,
and then I'm going to
put a little thin layer on top
of it with depth little d.
Or alternatively, I could strip
off, I could evaporate,
a layer of depth little d.
That would make the
seawater saltier.
With that geometric
interpretation, I can write
the ratio in my formula MW1 over
MW2 as being capital D
over capital D plus little d.
In other words, I'm just adding
water, and that's going
to change the mass ratio
before and after.
That allows me to rewrite this
formula finally to can you see
it if I do it here?
So I'm going to take this
formula, divide through by the
S1 and use little
added formula.
So delta S over S1 can be
written finally as big D over
D plus little d minus 1, which
can be simplified to little d
over big D plus little d.
That's the formula we're
going to use.
If that seems confusing in
any way, all I've done is
conserved salt, but change the
amount of fresh water, and
therefore the salinity
changes.
So if I add a layer of fresh
water of depth D with a minus
sign there, that's going to
make the water less salty.
The minus sign reminds
us of that.
If D is positive, if I've added
fresh water, the ocean
gets less salty.
If I subtract by evaporating,
then D would be negative.
Negative times a negative is
positive, and the salinity
would increase.
So that's the way you'd
use this formula.
Let's do an extreme
example to be sure
this formula's correct.
Let's say that I doubled
the depth.
I put a whole thick layer of
fresh water on there equal to
what I had originally
of seawater.
Well then it would be minus
capital D over capital D plus
capital D. That quantity is
going to be minus 1/2.
That means the salinity's going
to drop in half of what
it was before because
I've added an equal
amount of fresh water.
So that salt now had to
mix into twice the
amount of fresh water.
That's going to drop the
salinity exactly in half.
Now this would be an
extreme example.
Usually in the ocean we're just
talking about adding some
small fraction.
So let me do a little more
realistic example of this.
My example would be adding 1
meter of fresh water to 100
meters of ocean water.
How much will the
salinity change?
So delta S over S1 is going to
be minus 1 over 100 plus 1.
So that is approximately
minus 0.01.
This is approximately 35 parts
per thousand let's say, the
original salinity.
So delta S is going to
be 1/100th of that.
It's going to be 0.35 parts per
thousand, which means the
new S, the new salinity, I'll
call it here S2, is going to
be 34.65 parts per thousand.
I started with 35 parts per
thousand, 100 meter column,
added 1 meter of fresh water on
top, mixed it all in, the
salinity drops by 0.35 parts per
thousand, which takes me
from 35 to 36.65.
That would be a typical
situation.
And that's a big difference,
considering that the full
range of ocean salinity
is only from about
34 to 35 and 1/2.
That's a big difference
in ocean salinity.
And that'll cause circulations
to begin, because the seawater
density will have changed.
Any questions on that?
STUDENT: Is that only
for the surface?
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
STUDENT: Is that only
for the surface?
PROFESSOR: Yeah I don't
imagine well that's right.
So that would affect this
top 100 meters.
Then what happens later on to
the rest of the ocean, that
would remain to be seen.
If, for example, in this case,
I made it less dense, because
I made it less saline, that
water would probably remain
floating there.
If I had made it more dense, it
might find itself so dense
that it would then fall to
the bottom of the ocean.
But that's a separate
calculation.
Here I'm just trying to
understand what happens to the
surface water when you
change its salinity.
Now we turn to the third
type of forcing,
which is wind stress.
This is perhaps not quite as
obvious as the others.
I don't think I've greatly
surprised you by either of
these calculations here.
It's pretty much common sense.
But what happens when the wind
blows over the ocean?
When the wind blows
over the ocean it
produces a wind stress.
Frictionally, just like when you
move your hand across the
table pushing down, there's
a stress being
applied on that table.
That table starts to move
sometimes in the direction
that you're pushing.
And that's my question.
If I put the wind in that
direction, from left to right
in this diagram, does the ocean
water begin to move in
the same direction?
Well, you're probably on your
guard because you know that
the Coriolis force exists so
that some things are not quite
as obvious cause and effect-wise
when you have the
Coriolis force.
In fact, here's what happens.
So I'm going to draw a plan view
here now, North, South,
East and West. I'm going to
imagine I've got a Westerly
wind, that is a wind from West
to East. So the wind is
blowing in that direction.
The wind stress will also be
in that same direction.
I'd like to prove to you, in
the remaining three or four
minutes, that when I push the
water in that direction it
goes to the right.
It doesn't go in the direction
I'm pushing.
This will involve a new kind
of force balance called the
Ekman force balance.
It has something in common
with geostrophic force
balance, but it's also
quite different.
So let's say that I start to
put this wind stress, it's
going to--in the first few
minutes it is going to do the
obvious thing.
It's going to start the water
moving towards East. But then
as soon as it gets moving, if
feels the Coriolis force and
it will begin to bend.
After a few hours, I will argue
now, that the flow will
be towards the South that'll
be the Ekman flow.
To the right angles of that
will be the Coriolis force
acting on that Ekman flow.
And that's going to be equal
and opposite to the wind
stress itself.
And so when you push on the
water on a rotating Earth with
the frictional stress from the
wind, instead of moving in the
direction you push, it moves
at right angles.
To the right in the Northern
Hemisphere, to the south--I'm
sorry, to the left in the
Southern Hemisphere.
We could do a calculation.
I probably don't have time to
finish this today, but I can
do a calculation of how fast
that water will move.
If I have, again, a column of
depth D, it has a mass given
by AD rho across the area, the
height of the column, and the
density of seawater.
If it begins to move you'll have
a Coriolis force given by
2, the mass, the speed, the
rotation rate of the Earth,
and the sign of the latitude.
That's going to have to balance
the wind stress.
There's a nice empirical formula
for wind stress that
I'll give you.
I won't derive it, it's just
an observational quantity.
I've written there empirical,
which means it's an
experimentally-derived
formula.
It's given by constant 0.003
times the density of the air
blowing over the water's
surface times
the wind speed squared.
And this has units of Newtons
per square meter.
So now, let me just equate those
two things following the
prescription for the Ekman
layer force balance.
I'm going to say when you've got
a well established balance
of this sort, then the Coriolis
force which is 2, let
me substitute this in for MD
rho then comes U omega sin
phi, must be equal to Taw acting
on that same area A.
Since that's a force per unit
area, I need to multiply it by
a surface area to
get a Newton.
So I got Newtons and Newtons
on both sides.
And then solving this for the
speed of the flow in the Ekman
layer, I can cancel the A's,
and I have Taw over 2D rho
omega sign phi, sign
of the latitude.
That is the box formula for
this part of how the
atmosphere drives the ocean.
If I know the wind speed
I can compute Taw.
If I know Taw, the depth of
the layer that's being
influenced directly, the density
of seawater, the
rotation rate of the earth,
and the latitude, I can
compute how fast this water
moves off to the right under
the influence of the
wind stress.
So we're out of time today.
This needs a lot more
discussion.
But you've got a problem you're
working on for the
problem sets where you need to
use that formula, I believe.
And I will talk more about the
physics of this on Friday.